there's another teacher who just went
viral this from our friends over at libs
of tick tock
a teacher a black teacher
who is threatening
white people on purely on the basis of
racial animus
black people black people colors only i
got a question so you ever standing in
public right you stand in public and you
see white people do you ever get the
urge to just
you know
you know like you're minding your
business like they're kind of minding
their business and you just
just scared someone
just disappeared just stare a little bit
just to scare them a little bit just to
give them the feeling like today's the
day today's the day that black people
start retaliating just to give them a
little bit of it the burning feeling
inside
no just me um let me know
today's the day today's that okay now
i'm gonna go teach your kids your kids
of all different races even the ones
that i hate
even even the students
whom i hate
on the basis of their race
because of my ideology that says that
all white people are oppressors and all
black people are oppressed and it it's
an ideology that comes straight out of
marxism the sort of later stages of 20th
century marxism yeah i'm going to be the
ones teaching your kids isn't that a
good idea
my issue here
is not
that the teacher is making a joke i hope
it's a joke my issue here is not even
that the teacher is making a racial joke
i think racial jokes are fine i think
jokes about ethnicities and cultures and
yes even races if they're made in good
faith and good fun are totally fine
my issue here is that the teacher is
making comments
that are clearly not in good fun clearly
not in good faith and that the teacher
has a very perverse ideology that is
going to destroy the education of her
students and so she should not be
allowed to teach the kids she should be
fired simple as that okay that's how
we're going to wield power
the way we're going to wield power is if
yes we go to the school boards yes we
complain yes we go elect people but
you've you've got to get into the
classrooms
okay you've got it goes without saying i
don't even want to say it
it's so lame
every time a conservative but you know
what is the conservative they say well
imagine imagine if the roles were
reversed imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot and you had a teacher let's
say you had a i don't know a hispanic
teacher walking in and saying hey
whenever you see black people don't you
just want to threaten them don't you
just want a guy and say today's the day
well of course that's that's not that's
not the way that it works it's silly and
impotent to just complain and say well
what if what if the shoe was on the
other foot what if the rolls were
reversed that's not the way it is we are
living in a particular circumstance
in our classrooms in our politics and we
need to deal with that and this teacher
teaching students is not going to be
good for white kids not going to be good
for black kids it's not going to be good
for any kind of kids because this
teacher is teaching
things that are false and then also a a
real
sort of vitriol a real sort of
resentment that is not conducive to
education fire the teacher simple as
that there's a lot to get to but first
march 2nd is ash wednesday and over a
billion people will start living
different in some way
maybe giving up chocolate or alcohol or
whatever for a lot of folks lent is a
time of finding the easiest way to give
something up
but at the end of those 40 days did that
sacrifice really make a difference this
year there's a new opportunity out there
specifically for men that will actually
help you grow closer to god and become
better man you might have heard me talk
about exodus 90 but let me tell you
about exodus lent a 40-day journey that
will challenge you to dig a little
deeper this year here's how it works
first over the 40 days of lent men
commit to daily prayer setting aside a
minimum of 20 minutes to spend with the
lord each day includes a scripture
reading and reflection written to help
men better understand to grow in and
live virtue second more than just giving
up chocolate men take up a range of
disciplines and sacrifices for the
season of lent sweets snacks social
media all gone third men commit to a
fraternity of five to seven men each
week the fraternity meets to pray
together check in hold each other
accountable and encourage one another on
easter sunday you'll walk away with a
new and wonderful understanding of what
it means to live the full christian life
chocolate bunnies and all sign up at
exodus 90.com
michael
i'm glad you liked that clip you know
what you can do to get more clips you
can ring the bell subscribe to the
michael knowles show if you're not
getting notifications for whatever
reason youtube head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]